[संगीत]
खुदा
सो हेलो
बाकी अगर आप चेक करो तो सब कुछ दीपाली हो
चुका है एक चीज बताइए
मैं हूं आर्थिक आशीर्वाद सिटी ऑफ डेफिनेशन
सिक्योरिटी तो आज मैं आपको बनाने वाला
दे नाइट चल रहा है अपना आज का जिन लोगों
ने पहले के नहीं कर रहे हैं वो प्लीज पहले
के भी करके आना होगा आप लोगों के मेरी
आवाज ए रही हो ए रही है ठीक है
हां
तो यार देखो
अभी अपने इतना कुछ किया यार कभी-कभी अपना
सर अपना ऐसा क्या होता है ना की कोई है ना
वेजिटेबल है उसमें से अपन ने एक आउटपुट
निकाला फिर वह जो पहले आउटपुट निकाला है
सिलेक्ट करके उसमें अपन को उसे आउटपुट में
और सारे
कंडीशंस वगैरा डालनी है और उसे आउटपुट में
से भी अपन को आउटपुट निकालना होता है
है तो उसे कैसे में अपने पास क्या राहत है
ना अपन उसे कैसे में व्यू करते हैं व्यू
का इस्तेमाल करते हैं व्यू एक अपने
स्टोर्ड क्वेरी होता है जो अपन क्वेरी
एग्जीक्यूट कर दिए होते हैं किसी टेबल के
अंदर या फिर आ अपन ने कोई टेबल बनाई और
उसके बाद अपन को उसके अंदर कोई लिखने हैं
तो व्यू के अंदर वो ओपन करें स्टोर कर
देते हैं ताकि क्या राहत है ना की अपना
क्वेरी का जो आउटपुट होता है ना वो ऐसा
व्यू बन के बैंक दिखे जाता है व्यू अपन को
एक टेबल की तरह ही लगता है लेकिन अपने
वर्चुअल टेबल होती है 80 टेबल नहीं होती
है पब्लिक वर्चुअल टेबल होती है ठीक है ना
पुरानी टेबल के ऊपर बेस्ड एक और टेबल बनी
होती है
ठीक है ना तो उसके लिए क्या सीन राहत है
की अपन फिर जैसे अपन ने एक टेबल पे क्वेरी
चलाई फायरिंग का जो आउटपुट है आउटपुट के
और चलानी होगी तो अपन व्यू बनके उसका और
फिर उसके ऊपर चला सकते हैं
ये वाले समझ में ए रही होगी ठीक है ना
तो अभी अपन एक इसका लाइव एग्जांपल करके
देखते हैं की कैसा राहत है क्या राहत है
इसका तो
इसके साथ में
कनेक्ट कर लेते हैं
ठीक है
अभी टेबल आने के बाद में
क्या सीन
ऊपर वाली
ठीक है ना तो व्यू का सिंटेक्स क्या राहत
है अपना देखो मैंने इसके अंदर अपने लिखा
हुआ है व्यू के अंदर क्रिएट व्यू और व्यू
नाम आगे सिलेक्ट और फिर कलम का नाम फ्रॉम
टेबल और मेरे कंडीशन अगर रखूंगा लगानी है
तो यहां पर मैं लिखेंगे
टेबल्स नहीं बंटी है पेड़ का मांस है और
भी चीज बंटी है बिकॉज़ बनते हैं अपना
इंडेक्स बंता है अपना सीक्रेट बंता है
अपना प्रोसीजर बंता है अपने फंक्शंस बनते
हैं बहुत साड़ी चीज अपनी बंटी है और जो
चीज अपनी क्रिएट कमांड से बन रही है ना वो
चीज अपने ड्रॉप कमांड से उड़ेगी रेनवाल
ड्रॉप्स अपने टेबल ही उड़ता है अपना
क्रिएट क्रिएट कमांड से जो भी चीज अपन
बनाएंगे वो सर चीज अपना उससे उड़ेगा ठीक
है
तो क्रिएट व्यू
और
यह एमपी दाल देते हैं
ऐसे कॉपी करके पेस करूंगा
एक कम करो
मैंने उसका व्यू बना लिया अब इतनी सी
कमांड के थ्रू मैं यह पूरा मैं आउटपुट देख
सकता हूं ठीक है ना जब मैं इस में टेबल
में फिनिश करूंगा तो मेरा यहां पर भी चेंज
होने के चांसेस अगर अपने कंडीशंस के ऊपर
बेस करके क्योंकि मैंने ये स्कैनर अपना
आउटपुट स्टोर नहीं होता है इसके अंदर अपने
क्वेरी स्टोर होता है स्टोर्ड क्वेरी कहते
हैं इसको ऊपर ठीक है ना आउटपुट स्टोर
आउटपुट मेरे पास आपको एक एग्जांपल के लिए
बताया की अपना आउटपुट स्केनर शुरू हो जाता
है लेकिन क्वेरीज इन डी स्टोर होती है
स्टोर करियर रहती है इसके अंदर
ठीक है तो हां तो अगर अपन चाहते तो इसके
अंदर अब और भी कंडीशन लगा सकते हो जैसे
यहां पर अभी लिख देंगे
आउटपुट लिखा था ना तो अपन उसके अंदर भी और
और भी मतलब आउटपुट और भी तरीके से निकाल
सकते हैं
अपने उसका क्या कहते हैं
ठीक है तो यह क्या बात है आप लोग समझे समझ
गए होंगे ये एक स्टोर्ड अपना
स्टोर ही राहत है ठीक है ना जिसके अंदर एक
क्वेरी लिखी अपन को उसके अंदर और भी तो
देखिए चेंज चाहिए मतलब और भी तरीके और भी
नए तरीके से शॉर्ट फूड चाहिए तो अपन और भी
इसके अंदर चेंज वगैरा कर सकते हैं हां
कोर्स बात है इसके अलावा इनसाइड इंसर्ट
वगैरा नहीं कर सकते क्योंकि ये अपना टेबल
नहीं है
इसके लिए
ठीक है अब जैसे मैंने कहा की जो चीज की
रेट से क्रिएट होती है वो सिर्फ ड्रॉप भी
होती है तो ये अपन इसको ड्रॉप करेंगे
ड्रॉप
हो गया
नहीं डालते हैं
नॉर्मली टेबल
का आउटपुट देने में बहुत दिक्कत आई है
ठीक है ना तो अपन किसी भी चीज की तो उसका
आउटपुट बहुत दिक्कत आई है तो उसके लिए
क्या करना पड़ता है ना अपना आउटपुट थोड़ा
फास्ट तरीके से आए तो अपन इंडेक्स बना के
रख देते हैं
ताकि ये क्या राहत है ना
की उसका आउटपुट जल्दी आता है इंडेक्स
एप्पल को सामने शो नहीं होता अगर आप
इंडेक्स को देखना चाहोगे तो इंडक्शन देख
नहीं सकते हो ये सिस्टम के इंटरनल ही कम
करता है ठीक है ना ये अपन को बाहर से नहीं
बस अगर आप बनाए गए छोड़ डॉग तो वैसे बन
जाएगा ऐसा कुछ उसके अंदर राहत नहीं है ठीक
है इसकी मां के साथ कम करता है ये इंटरनल
आउटपुट अच्छा करने में कम कम करते हैं और
खुद इसका इतना में रूल नहीं है
टेबल के कलम को करते हैं
सेट करने की कोशिश करूंगा तो क्या होता है
जरा देखते हैं अपन
के लिए इंडेक्स का नाम रखते हैं
यहां पर टेबल का नाम अपना
एम्पलाई
एमपी आईडी
ठीक है
जो प्राइमरी की होती है
और इसके अलावा
अगर आप प्राइमरी के थ्रू कोई भी वैल्यू को
रिट्रीव करना चाहोगे तो बहुत फास्ट वे में
होगा
प्राइमरी की था अब इसकी जगह पर मैं अगर
नाम का इस्तेमाल करता हूं यहां पर ठीक है
ना तो वो वहां पर इंडेक्स बन जाएगा
ठीक है इंडेक्सिंग लगाने के बाद आपको ऐसे
सामने आपको ऐसे पता नहीं लगेगा लेकिन बिग
डाटा वगैरा के अंदर आपको पता लगेगा चीज को
आप इसको करेंगे प्रैक्टिस में तो आपको
लगेगा हां कुछ चेंज ए रहे हैं ठीक है
तो उसे कैसे में अपने कम आता है उसके
अलावा अपना इंडेक्स कितना कुछ कम नहीं
होना बिल्कुल सिलेक्ट करके ऐसे देख सकते
हो लेकिन आज सिलेक्ट करें क्रिएट कमेंट से
क्रिएट करते हैं वो ड्रॉप का वहां से
ड्रॉप ही होता है
समझ में आया व्यू और इंडेक्स
सुना है की नहीं
चलो बढ़िया बात है की समझ में आया तो हां
अब देखो
एक 102 103 104 105 106 107 108 109 ऐसे
लिखना पड़ता है
रहती है
ठीक है
तो मतलब कभी-कभी
सेट करना चाहूंगा तो वो कैसे सीक्वेंस
होगा ना
जैसे मैं कम करता हूं इसको
स्टार्ट किस करना है अब देखो 109 है तो
मुझे 169 से स्टार्ट करना है
इंक्रीमेंट करना मुझे इंक्रीमेंट बाय वन
होता है
109 ठीक है मैक्स वैल्यू मैक्स वैल्यू
कितना भी रख सकते हैं
109 तक
1999 तक अपना ये हो गया ठीक है
होने के बाद में
अपना साइकिल को रिपीट करना है की नहीं
आपको एक्शन 99 के बाद में ये 109 से चालू
हो जाएगा वापस से तो उसके लिए अपन क्या
करेंगे ना यहां पर नो साइकिल लिख देंगे
नहीं रिएक्शन
दिखा दो या फिर मैं खुद से एक्शन चालू कर
दूंगा
ठीक है अब देखो मेरे को यहां 104 की जगह
पर अभी मैं क्या लिखूंगा यहां पर
आईडी ठीक है या लिखूंगा फिर अपना
यहां पर और यहां पर जैसे अगर मुझे नाम
देना हो जाएगा तो आज मिलेगी नया नया नाम
देखा है वो भी यार और बीट
एस ठीक है ना अब यहां पे मुझे नंबर नहीं
देना पड़ेगा क्योंकि अभी मैंने यूनिक
कांस्टेंट दाल रखा है तो यहां पर इसको
बैंड कर देता हूं
महाराष्ट्र की जगह पर मैं यहां पर कुछ भी
एकदम मुझे अप लिख देता हूं
ठीक है
अभी रॉक लेट हो गया
तो अभी मैं देखूंगा नया पर सिलेक्ट स्टार
फ्रॉम
एम्पलाइज तो देखो यहां पर
देखो मैं यहां पर
राम राम लिख देते हैं
की अभी करंट वैल्यू क्या चल रही है देखो
जैसे अगर अपनी है अभी क्या राहत है ना की
जैसे डेवलपर चेंज हुआ या फिर डीजे चेंज
हुआ तो नई बीबी को आगे चेक करनी पड़ती है
की यार की अभी क्या चल रहा है कैसे क्या
हो रहा है तो उसके लिए है ना वो यहां पर
चेक कर सकते हैं यहां से सिलेक्ट
सिलेक्ट लिखकर आईडी
क्या होता है
खाली टेबल बनी हुई रहती है ठीक है
कुछ भी बनाते हो तो अब इस ड्यूल टेबल
के अंदर टेस्टिंग करो
तो सिलेक्ट स्टार सिलेक्ट पर यह एमपी रोड
करंट वैल्यू से मुझे 111 वाला अपना वैल्यू
है 111 ए गया जैसे मैं और कुछ डाटा इंसर्ट
करूंगा तो यहां पर अगर मैं चेकिंग चेकिंग
करूंगा तो यहां पे 112 लिखा हुआ ए जाएगा
ठीक है ना तो
ये खाली टेबल रहती है वन बाय वन की ठीक है
ना
पापा ऐसे करके देख सकते हो
आपके सामने
इंक्रीमेंट बाय वैल्यू स्टार्ट
होता है
लेकिन अभी अपने टेबल
सीक्वेंस के बड़े में समझ में आएगी
सीक्वेंस कैसे कम करता है कैसे बकरा में
इसकी जिंदगी में आसानी से लाकर राखी हुई
है
समझ में आया की नहीं प्लीज यार चाट के
अंदर
वेटिंग
अच्छा चलो बढ़िया है
तू ठीक है
ठीक है
तो देखो प्यार
डिफॉल्ट अपना हुआ था
यूजर सिस्टम
आपको एक आपने किसी दूसरे आपका असिस्टेंट
को आपने ही किया और आप उसको उससे यूजर
बनाना चाहते हो की वो सिस्टम से लॉगिन ना
करके उसके एक अलग से यूजर है और उसके अंदर
वो जो मतलब वो अपने हिसाब से जो करना चाहे
वो कर ले लेकिन उसके कुछ भी कम करने से
आपके में टेबल के अंदर कोई इफैक्ट्स वगैरा
ना पड़े
ठीक है तो उसके लिए आपका एक यूजर बनाकर
डॉग ठीक है ना तो एक यूजर कैसे बनाते हैं
जैसे मां लो की मैंने एक
भाई नाम से मैंने यूजर बनाना चाहता हूं तो
मैं यहां पर क्या लिखूंगा ना सिंपली
क्रिएट
आईडेंटिफिकली
लेट हूं
ठीक है
परमिशन नहीं दे राखी है
पहले मैं ऊपर वाले कमांडो
इस यूजर को सेशन बनाने की परमिशन ही नहीं
है ठीक है तो क्या इसका क्या मतलब होता है
नहीं की यार अपन ने इसको कनेक्ट करने का
प्रिविलेज नहीं दे रखा है तो अपन को उसको
प्रिविलेज भी देने का सबसे पहले बट अभी
अपन कुछ भी करेंगे ना तो वो होगा नहीं
क्योंकि अभी अपन और एक अच्छे कनेक्ट ही
नहीं है जो अपन सिस्टम से जो कनेक्ट थे
यूजर से वह वेस्टर्न डिस्कनेक्ट कर दिया
है मैं अगर कुछ भी अभी कमांड लिखूंगा ना
तो यहां पर
तो ये मुझे नो नोट कनेक्ट लिखा कर दिखाएगा
तो सबसे पहले अभी मुझे कलेक्ट करने का है
कनेक्ट सिस्टम
तो अभी मुझे ना इनको
कनेक्ट कर सके
तू यूजर का नाम है
मेरे सामने ठीक है तो अभी मैं ना इस यूजर
से कनेक्ट कर सकता हूं ठीक है
तो मैं अगर यहां पर एमपी टेबल को देखना
चाहता हूं
मुझे क्योंकि मैंने इस यूजर को जो सिस्टम
की जो टेबल थी उसे टेबल को सिलेक्ट करने
का मैंने परमिशन ही नहीं दिया है तो यहां
पर उसको किसी भी कंडीशन में सिलेक्ट नहीं
कर सकता है
ग्रैंड सिलेक्ट
जो टेबल का नाम दूंगा मैं इसको
करने का है सिलेक्ट
अपने यूजर का नाम क्या है
स्टार फ्रॉम सिस्टम
हो सकता है पहले मैंने यह चीज कारी थी यह
देखो पहले मैंने यह चीज कारी थी तो यहां
पर टेबल नोट एक्जिस्ट करके दिखा रहा था
इसलिए देखा की आपको प्रोग्रेस नहीं मिला
यार देखो यार बहुत दिक्कत होती है ये ये
सुनकर की है रात को परमिशन नहीं मिला ठीक
है ना आप मां लो की अपने गर्लफ्रेंड का
फोन उठाके देख रहे हो और उसके बाद में आप
उसका फोन एक्सेस नहीं कर पता तो यार आपको
दिल में बहुत शॉर्ट पोस्ती किया मैं मेरी
गर्लफ्रेंड तक का फोन नहीं एक्सेस कर सकता
तो इस चक्कर में क्या किया ना अभी
गर्लफ्रेंड नहीं है की यार मैं खुद भी
पासवर्ड भूल गई हूं ठीक है ना तो उसमें
आपको इतना दुख नहीं होगा
क्या उसको कोई पासवर्ड नहीं पता मुझे भी
नहीं पता बस तो चलो अच्छी बात है तो और है
कल भी अपने दर्द समझना है
की यार आप निठल्ले हो आपको ये तक में दिया
गया प्रिविलेज एक सिलेक्ट करने का
प्रिविलेज भी नहीं दिया गया है स्केनर आप
टेबल में घंटा कुछ चेंज नहीं कर सकते ठीक
है ना सिलेक्ट कमांड से तो वो भी आपको
प्रिविलेज नहीं दिया
अपनी तो स्टेट टेबल और व्यू नोट है जी
करके आउटपुट दिखा दिया लेकिन हकीकत में
ऐसा नहीं है भाई ठीक है हकीकत में यही है
की आपको आप आपको परमिशन नहीं दी हुई आपको
आपके डीडीएल ने परमेश्वर आपका द्वार पर
ट्रस्ट ही नहीं करता ठीक है ना तो उसका सर
फोड़ के बोलो मुझे परमिशन दो तो वो आपको
ऐसे करके परमिशन देगा ठीक है तो फिर जाके
आप एक्सेस कर सकते हो
एक्सेस करना है उसका नाम
लिखना पड़ता है
इंसर्ट करने का ट्राई करो यहां पर
पंजाब में एक बड़ी कर देता हूं और
एम्पलाई किया तो यहां पर टेबल
लिखा है
टेबल नहीं है तो मैं अगर सिस्टम वाले के
अंदर अगर डालना चाहूं सिस्टम
मत करो
इंसर्ट
जो
तू केयर
लगा सकता हूं
ठीक है
तो मेरे को अपडेट करने के लिए कौन सी
कमांड
लिखकर दिखा सुकून
प्लीज मुझे बताओ मैं कैसे अपडेट कर सकता
हूं अपडेट कमांड का सेल टैक्स करके दिखा
दो मुझे बस
लगता है आप लोग को शायद
जो मैं करवा रहा हूं याद ही नहीं राहत यार
अपना सिस्टम
वंडर ऑफ डिटेल
नहीं करता ठीक है तो मैं यहां पर अपडेट
नहीं कर पता वैल्यू अब देखो यार मैं चाहता
हूं की यार ये अपना मैं वो तो ना ऐसा की
कैप बेवफा लिख ले लेकिन अगर मां लो कल को
बेवफा लिखने हैं ये तो उसे कैसे में मैं
क्या करूंगा ना मैं इसे प्रिविलेज ले
लूंगा ठीक है ना
इंस्टाग्राम का पासवर्ड नहीं दूंगा
तो उसके लिए
सबसे पहले सिस्टम वाले इसमें चला जाता हूं
ठीक है
उनको अपने ही डाटा अपडेट करनी चाहिए थे
उन्होंने मेरे किसी दूसरे मेरे एक्स्ट्रा
मैसेज क्यों सीन कर लिया मैं इस चीज से
बहुत दुखी हो गया था मुझे उनसे लेना है
मेरा अकाउंट का ठीक है
तो उसके लिए मैं क्या करूंगा
अपडेट
ठीक है
मैं यहां पर रीबॉक
नहीं होगी ठीक
है
कंट्रोल लैंग्वेज
चलो बढ़िया है अगर आप लोगों को समझ में ए
रहा हो तो देखो जैसे अभी यह यूजर बना है
तो जैसे मैंने यह आप क्रिएट कमेंट करके
ड्रॉप भी कर सकते हो तो ड्रॉप यूजर कब
तो यूजर ड्रॉप अब अब क्या मैंने पूरा यूजर
से हटा ही दिया है ठीक है
ठीक है तो
ऐसे में उनसे कनेक्ट की परमिशन भी ले सकता
था रे वह कनेक्ट करके रिवॉर्ड कनेक्ट
फ्रॉम एन कैश खरीदे हुए कनेक्ट वैसे ही
नहीं कर पाते बट मैंने पूरा अब मेरे दिल
से इतना ऐसा बोझ हो गया की मेरे को सारे
फोटोस इनके डिलीट करने पड़े तो इसके लिए
मैंने डिलीट कर दिया आता इसमें नहीं डाला
है सर डिलीट कर दिया मैंने ट्रैक से बैठा
दिया अब ठीक है ना तो ऐसा अपना राहत है
अपना जो भी किड का मां क्रिएट कारी होती
है उसको आप ड्रॉप कमल के ड्रॉप कर सकते हो
ठीक है अब जो चीज आपने की आ परमिशन ग्रांट
कारी है वो उसे रीबॉक से आप एनीमेशन ले भी
सकते हो सिंगल परमेश्वर ने मल्टी परमिशन
ले सकते हो एक साथ में सारे मिशन देने के
लिए आप जो का भी इस्तेमाल कर सकते हो
साड़ी इनफॉरमेशन लेने के लिए ठीक है तो
होप आप लोगों को एसक्यूएल का अच्छा लगा हो
तो आइसक्रीम बट हां आप लोगों के लिए एक
छोटी सी अनाउंसमेंट है एक बढ़िया तरीके से
ठीक है ना हम लोग एक इंटर्नशिप
अपॉर्चुनिटी प्रोवाइड करने वाले हैं
सिक्योरिटी की तरफ से ठीक है ना इसके अंदर
हम लोग पाइथन का और साइबर सिक्योरिटी को
मिक्स करके एक मिनी प्रोजेक्ट लॉन्च करने
वाले हैं
ठीक है तो इंटेंसिव करेंगे और इंटर्नशिप
के अंदर जो जो भी लोग इंटेंस रहेंगे उन सब
वह सब लोग मिलकर अपन एक मिली प्रोजेक्ट
बनाएंगे साथ बैठ के इसके अंदर होप सो मैं
भी रहूंगा ठीक है
तो अपन लोग साथ में मिलकर एक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी का ही मिनी प्रोजेक्ट बनाएंगे
और फरदर अनाउंसमेंट के लिए आपको हमारे
टेलीग्राम चैनल को सब्सक्राइब करके रखना
है और आपके जो भी दोस्त लोग हैं जो लोग
चाहते हैं पैठण के साथ मिलकर एक साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर एक प्रोजेक्ट बनाना
साथ में बैठ के सब लोग ग्रुप बनाना है
इंडिविजुअल का भी देख लेंगे अगर आपको
आइडिया ग जाए की कैसे करते हो आप
इंडिविजुअल प्रोजेक्ट बना सकते हो अपना
ठीक है
बट एक इंटर्नशिप ऑपच्यरुनिटीज साइबर
सिक्योरिटी लॉन्च करने वाला है अपना तो आप
लोग अपने जो भी चैनल वगैरा एक ग्रुप से
अगर आपके पास जो कुछ भी है वहां हर जगह
फैलाओ तो आपके दोस्त लोग जो लोग भी आना
चाहते हैं ठीक है वह सारे के सारे लोग ए
सकते हैं हमारे इंटेलिजेंस ग्राफ कर सकते
हैं और जो डीटेल्स अगर के लिए आपको हमारे
टेलीग्राम चैनल के अंदर ही आपको हमारा और
डीटेल्स वगैरा पता ग जाएंगे वहां पर जाकर
तो आप लोग जहां पे हो सके वहां पर दाल दो
ताकि जितने ज्यादा जेल हो सके उतनी ज्यादा
जानें वहां पर आकर हमारे साथ इंटर्नशिप
में जॉइन हो सकते हैं ठीक है तो हमारा
टेलीकॉम चैनल जॉइन कर लेना
आप डालोगे सर्च के अंदर तो हमारा ए जाएगा
तो वहां पे आपको सारे के सारे अपडेट्स
वगैरा वहां पर मिल जाएंगे तो वहां से अपने
इंटर्नशिप आप चाहे तो आप भी गलत कर सकते
हो ठीक है एक बहुत बढ़िया इंटरेस्ट है हम
लोग को एड करेंगे ताकि आप लोग भी अपने सी
व्यूज वगैरा के अंदर आप वो हमारा
इंटर्नशिप का दाल सकते हो उसकी भी बहुत
वैल्यू मिलेगी आपको सब कुछ सर्टिफाइड चीज
आपको प्रोवाइड होएगी ठीक है सेटिस्फाइड
ट्रेलर्स के थ्रू
तो
आज के लिए बस इतना ही ठीक है आप लोग जितना
भी पहले सब कुछ कराया उत्तर सब कुछ आज तक
का एकदम पूरा रिवाइज करो मतलब बढ़िया
तरीके से एकदम फाड़ दो एक चीज अपना देव
रहेगा और वो जी कंट्री में सिर्फ तभी होगा
जब आप लोग इस सीरीज को बहुत अच्छे तरीके
से देखेंगे आगे लेकर जाएंगे तो मैं आपको
यहां पर लाइव आकर अपना एसक्यूएल का
इंजेक्शन करके दिखाएंगे अपने ही डेटाबेस
के अंदर दाल के ठीक है हो सके और और अच्छा
अगर तरीका है तो मैं खुद कहीं लेफ्ट सेटअप
करने वाले हैं करेंगे और लेफ्ट सेटअप कैसे
कर रहे हैं वह भी साथ में यहां पर लाइव
करेंगे
कैसे वो कम कर रहा है वह सब यहां पर लाइव
ही ओपन करेंगे इसको इंजेक्शन का अगर इस
सीरीज पर अच्छे खेस अगर आप लोगों ने
रिस्पांस किया तो ठीक है तो होप सो आप लोग
देखते हैं आप लोग कितना अच्छे तरीके से
इसके रिस्पांस करते हैं तो फिर जाके जो
मेरे देव चीज है उसको ओपन कंटिन्यू करेंगे
लाइव आकर यहां पर
लाइव स्कोर इंजेक्शन का अपन करके देखेंगे
अपने जो जो कुछ भी शिखा है वह सब कुछ लाइव
इंप्लीमेंटेशन
वेबसाइट पर भी जा सकते हैं अगर गूगल भी
करेंगे
तो हमारी ये वेबसाइट ए जाएगी ठीक है
यहां पर कुछ जितने भी टाइप के टूल्स वगैरा
होते हैं वह सारे टूल्स रूल्स आपको हमारे
शेव्रले नाम के टूल के अंदर आपको मिलेंगे
₹1000 कर सकते हो जो भी चीज मैन्युअल पढ़
सकते हो आपको साइबर सिक्योरिटी से रिलेटेड
कोई भी न्यूज़ होगी तो वो भी आप लोग यहां
पर हमारे स्टूडियो के थ्रू देख सकते हो
साथ कलर आप किसी भी चीज का मैन्युअल है या
फिर किसी भी चीज के बड़े में साइट है आप
डायरेक्टली हमारे चैनल पढ़ सकते हो ठीक है
और शादी के अंदर आपको कुछ भी वर्कशॉप
सॉल्यूशन ये हर चीजों के हर चीजों के लिए
हमारे सैफ्रॉनिक्स टूल ऐसे ही अपन और भी
टूल्स बना सकते हैं हमारे इंटर्नशिप
प्रोग्राम के अंदर तो क्लियर जॉइन करो देख
सकते हो यहां पे लिस्ट कितने सारे टूल हर
डोमेन का साइबर सिक्योरिटी के अंदर उन
सबके हर टूल्स आपको इसके अंदर मिलेंगे ठीक
है अगर आपको इसमें और भी इंप्रूवमेंट में
चाहिए टूल्स के अंदर तो आप हमको बताओ की
यहां पर इंप्रूवमेंट वगैरा चाहिए
तो वो भी हम लोग जरूर इसका नाम रख सकते
हैं तो ये आप देख सकते हो
अब आने वाले समय में अभी देखते हैं और
क्या क्या फल अपन लोग कर सकते हैं
तो गुड नाइट गैस टाटा बाय बाय सी यू सुन
और जय हिंद वंदे मातरम अब आगे और कुछ
सीरीज में मिलेंगे फिर से मैं हूं